a wonder junkie now you describe
yourself as a wonder junkie yeah explain
to us what this is sure what can we
learn from that so I'm a big fan of Carl
Sagan the famous astronomer and he used
to contemplate space and time on a scale
just shy of the infinite and there was
poetry in his contemplation you could
tell that the guy was was drunk on aw
his the way that he articulated both the
sublime and mystery of the cosmos and
our desire to understand such a mystery
resonated with me to no end one of my
favorite films growing up was contact
and that was a Robert Zemeckis film
based on a novel that Carl Sagan wrote
called contact so he was the original
novelist behind what I think is one of
the best science fiction stories of all
time and in the novel he was describing
the Ellie Arroway character who Jodie
Foster played in the film and he
described her as a wonder junkie when
trying to capture the essence of that
fire in the belly that faint disquiet
that insatiable curiosity with which he
probed at the infinity of the cosmos
like when she looked at the stars when
she contemplated space and time it
Hatchett ated her soul you know there
was this this this this ecstatic
question-asking and he referred to as a
wonder junkie which is a strong word
right because you think of a junkie you
think of heroin addict but so
essentially he was saying well that's
kind of what it is it's like you're
addicted the way a heroin addict is
addicted to heroin but you're addicted
to wonder and and I mean that spoke to
me so much that I felt like finally
somebody gets me you know I found myself
reflected in that phrase and there's
another phrase that speaks directly to
that thirst as well it's in line by f
scott Fitzgerald that I might have
referenced in my speech F scott
Fitzgerald was this was from an essay
called the death of aw and the age of
awesome
and and so the the author was enry wise
Meyer was quoting f scott Fitzgerald
from a line where he was describing
Dutch sailors discovering the new world
for the first time so this notion of
seeing the fresh green breasts of new
world and the line was man must have
held his breath compelled into an
aesthetic contemplation he neither
understood nor desired face to face
perhaps for the last time in history
with something could measure it to his
capacity for wonder and so it's like
something can measure his capacity for
wonder because jaded miss or cynicism
well Michael Pollan calls the bin
there's and scene that's of the adult
mind that assumption that we've seen it
all before that nothing really impresses
us that we don't really have to engage
with anything because we know what that
is so we can dispense with what's
happening at leapfrog to the conclusion
being there done that so to speak which
is such a contemporary thing these days
he says that that comes from a lack of
an experiential jolt that thrusts you
back into the mystery again you know
that you can have an experience where
you're cracked open that is finally
kamesha it with your capacity for wonder
and part of one of my demons I think is
that I'm terrified of becoming jaded you
know for me like existential despair is
to think that okay that's all there is
and there's nothing else and there's no
more awe and there's just resignation
and so I'm addicted to I think novelty
I'm addicted to new experiences to new
ideas you know under store to newer
forms of understanding and and and I
work really hard to seek out experiences
that that are kamesha it to my capacity
for wonder because very big that seems
like a really remarkable way to live
life now doesn't that go get you in
situations where you're freaking
frustrated because there isn't enough
wonder happening in your life doesn't it
make it hard to settle in one city or
yes stick to one job or one relationship
yes yes I think that's actually one of
the hardest things I think that in my
own life I remember living in Los
Angeles for five years working as a
television presenter and you know
I was living the dream I'm in Los
Angeles I'm going to parties in the
Hills and meeting celebrities and dating
actresses like life was good until that
was all there was until it became so
familiar and they say the familiarity
deadens you know routine makes
everything stale or at least it tends to
and that has to do with something called
hedonic adaptation so things that give
us pleasure eventually don't give us as
much pleasure it's why people who do
cocaine report never being able to get
the same high they got the first time I
would know I've never done cocaine but
um but this notion of hedonic adaptation
speaks to me very much because I think
it can happen in every context things
that give pleasure just don't give as
much pleasure once you adapt to them
once they you normalize to them and so
you have to shake things up in your own
life now not all of us are lucky enough
to travel the world you know to be
exposed to different people but but you
can be exposed to different books you
know you can go down different rabbit
holes on the internet you can take a
different commute to work you can take
up a different hobby
anything that thrusts you into a new
world you know and sometimes it doesn't
even mean that you'll find what you're
looking for but that the search is
enough I think it was Walker Percy who
wrote this line but from the moviegoer
that I love he says this search is what
anyone would undertake if they were not
sunk the everydayness of their own lives
and just to become aware of the
possibility of the search just the
possibility of the search is to be on to
something and not to be on to something
is to be in despair so I mean I'm sure
that resonates with you too because
sometimes it's just the possibility like
what's what's beyond beyond that corner
you know what's over there Who am I
gonna meet tomorrow what new email is
gonna come in you know
and and and organizing my life so that
surprises consistently arrive